invité de preuves par 3 françois de rugy
député écologiste bonsoir écologistes
c'est le nom que vous avez donnée au
mouvement vous avez lancé après avoir
quitté avec fracas l'été dernier europe
ecologie les verts mouvement gauchiste
selon vous est ce qui évidemment pèse
une lourde responsabilité en cette
période de progression constante du
front national sur cette question bien
sûr vous pourrez vous exprimer dans un
instant mais vous répondrai au cours de
cette émission à trois grandes questions
la coop 21 va-t-elle sauver la planète
deuxième question est ce que vous
craignez pour les libertés publiques
avec l'entrée en vigueur de l'état
d'urgence face aux dangers terroristes
qui menacent toujours notre pays
beaucoup de vos amis ou anciens amis
s'alarmer bien vous répondrais sur ce
point à perrine tarneaud de public sénat
enfin troisième question que vous posera
stéphanie le rouge de l' agence
france-presse
un parti écolo certes il encore à
quelque chose à quoi en effet à l'heure
où la main sur le coeur on l'a vu hier
tous les dirigeants de la planète ont
célébré l'environnement rivalisant de
volontarisme pour limiter la hausse de
la température mondiale
alors on va d'abord regarder un petit
florilège les présidents américain et
chinois s'il vous plaît au bourget hier
soir je suis ici en ma qualité de
dirigeant de l'une des plus grandes
économies du monde l'une des plus
grandes économies émettrices et je suis
tout à fait conscient que nous sommes à
la source de ce problème
il va de notre responsabilité d'y
remédier aujourd'hui tous les yeux se
tournent vers paris conjuguons nos
efforts de manière à ensemble contribuer
à la mise en place d'un mécanisme
mondial équitable et efficace face au
changement climatique
travaillons à trouver des solutions de
développement durable qu'ils soient
d'ordre mondial et ce au niveau le plus
élevé et faisons en sorte également
qu'une nouvelle coopération
internationale se met en place qui
permet à tous d'en sortir gagnant alors
françois de rugy ces belles paroles ça
vous rend confiants ou encore plus
vigilants c'est positif
il faut mesurer tout le chemin parcouru
à la précédente conférence mondiale de
lutte contre le changement climatique y
avait encore des gens qui contestait la
réalité du changement
matic il y avait des gens qui ne
voulaient pas s'engager dont la chine
qui disaient qu'ils étaient le pied sur
le frein qui disait c'est vous les
grands états industrialisés qu'ils
avaient beaucoup pollué jusqu'à présent
qui devait prendre des mesures et la
chine refusait les mesures
contraignantes
le contrôle des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre aujourd'hui l'état d'esprit des
chefs d'état et de gouvernement leur
déclaration beaucoup plus encourageant
maintenant évidemment on est il ya
encore du chemin à faire bon vivre à
jusqu'au même là la conclusion c'est le
samedi 12 décembre et bien il faut
encore négocier parce que c'est une
négociation pour arriver à un objectif
meilleur que celui que nous avons
aujourd'hui est ce que c'est le pape
françois qui résume le mieux la
situation en disant nous sommes au bord
du suicide
je ne crois pas que il fallait dire ça
bon moi je comprends ceux qui se disent
il faut encore éveillé les consciences
en quelque sorte mais moi je crois que
l'éveil des consciences il est fait
les mentalités ont changé je le vois en
france évidemment mais je crois qu en
europe dans le monde c'est le cas on
n'est plus dans la phase ii des veilles
des consciences on est dans la région
décision sans rédaction des résistances
et même des oppositions il ya des
climats sceptique on le voit notamment
aux états unis toute l'opposition
républicaine franchement oui aux etats
unis c'est sans doute le dernier pays où
il y a un très fort courant climato
sceptiques comme on dit qui remet en
cause même la réalité du changement
politique
l effet la droite américaine est sur
cette ligne là malheureusement ce qui
prouve d'ailleurs qu'il ya une
différence entre la gauche la droite en
la matière aux états unis et le
président obama lui a fait le choix de
s'engager et c'est une bonne chose parce
que c'est le premier pollueur du monde
alors c'est la question parce que là
comme matin va sauver la planète
elle savait des écologistes naturalistes
ont pour habitude de dire que c'est pas
tellement la planète qui a besoin d'être
sauvé parce qu'elle se sauverait tout
seul la planète c'est nous les êtres
humains c'est notre capacité à vivre
correctement sur la planète à ne pas
subir les conséquences du changement
climatique
aujourd'hui on peut les toucher du doigt
et ça aussi c'est important dans la
prise de conscience qu'il faut agir
c'est que même en france même dans un
pays comme la france qui n'est pas le
plus touché on voit des phénomènes
climatiques exceptionnels on voit la
montée des températures est ce que vous
êtes l'optimiste encore il ya quelques
heures la barack obama a dit nous allons
réussir sur votre conviction je crois
que c'est possible
je crois qu'il ya beaucoup de conditions
qui n'étaient pas réunies lors des
précédentes conférences qui aujourd'hui
sont réunis pour un accord est unanimité
d'abord et oui et puis pour avoir un
accord un accord qui sera de fait
contraignant se donnent des objets
confiés en croyant faire et dans le
temps la vérifier a alors levé rame
encore débat oui mais c'est la mienne
gala en noir et l'administration obama
n'est pas d'accord sur ce point beaudry
mais c'est une dynamique qui aujourd'hui
engage les pays les uns avec les autres
savez on dit on va pas prendre des
sanctions contre un pays qui ne
respecteraient pas ces objectifs
et pourquoi pas on voit qu'on prend des
sanctions économiques dans d'autres
conflits dans d'autres tensions
internationales et que ça produit ses
effets un état comme la chine par
exemple ne pourrais pas vivre
durablement son modèle économique est
fondé sur les exportations ne peut pas
vivre durablement si jamais il y avait
des sanctions économiques
il avait relevé elle fait assaut de
bonne volonté on va écouter françois
hollande maintenant qu'ils passaient
ainsi hier matin à l'inauguration de la
conférence
les enjeux pour résoudre la crise
climatique
je vous le dis franchement les bons
sentiments qui les déclarations
d'intention ne suffiront pas nous sommes
au bord d'un point de rupture
paris doit être le départ d'une profonde
mutation
nous ne pouvons plus considérer la
nature comme un vulgaire et inépuisable
réservoir de ressources destinées à
notre seule et plein accomplissement
voilà le chef de l'état qui met en garde
contre les bons sentiments et
aujourd'hui on entendu manuel valls
précisé qu'il fallait prendre en compte
les spécificités de certains pays
comment est ce que vous comprenez cette
phrase c'est normal c'est les pays ne
sont pas tous dans la même situation en
termes d'émissions de gaz à effet de
serre la france n'est pas dans la même
situation que l'allemagne qui n'est pas
l'europe n'est pas aimé moins que les
états unis par exemple où le canada ou
l'australie qui sont très gros émetteur
ou la chine aujourd'hui après si vous
ramenez au nombre d'habitants une
annonce à change puisque la chine est un
pays parfait comme ça que vous comprenez
les choses au oui parce que c'est normal
je vois des objectifs qui soit réaliste
il faut des objectifs ambitieux mais il
faut ça sert à rien de placé la barre
tellement haut que personne ne pourrais
le latin comment est ce que vous êtes
réaliste à l'heure avec l'inde par
exemple
qui aujourd'hui on a entendu son premier
ministre bourget hier considéré que les
énergies fossiles sont indispensables à
son pays pour attirer sa croissance et
sortir la population de s'appauvrir
terme c'est sans doute vrai que vrai
pour un pays comme l'inde et dieu fait
il ya des pays comme les pays européens
qui peuvent faire beaucoup plus
d'efforts puisqu'ils ont les
technologies cei par exemple qu'en
europe on pourrait fermer des centrales
à charbon et les remplacer par des
centrales à gaz qui sont beaucoup moins
émettrices à terme il faudra nous nous
pensons un scénario 100% énergies
renouvelables et dans la transition
le gaz par exemple et même beaucoup
moins que le charbon aujourd'hui en
europe il y à des centrales à gaz
neuf qui sont à l'arrêt simplement parce
qu'on a laissé par faiblesse politique
les centrales à charbon alors il est où
les vieilles centrales en europe et en
france il ya aussi des centrales
nucléaires mais certains spécialistes
scientifiques disent elles font partie
de la solution aussi mais vous savez il
ya des centrales nucléaires en france on
est le pays le plus nucléarisé au monde
pour ce qui est de la production
d'électricité et déjà ramené à toute
l'énergie dans le monde c'est
infinitésimal
donc personne n'imagine que demain la
solution ce soit clair et je vais vous
dire il n'ya pas la solution
l'énergie le défi énergétique allié de m
voilà c'est une palette de technologies
c'est une palette de moyens y compris
dans les changements de comportement et
qui va permettre d'abord d'économiser
l'énergie de produire autant voire plus
qu'en consommant moins d'énergie de sang
l'a déjà démontré c'est déjà une réalité
c'est là aussi qu'il faut être positif
l'industrie les particuliers les
transports ont fait déjà beaucoup de
progrès il y en a encore beaucoup à
coeur non mais je reviens sur ce que
vous avez dit sur l'un donc vous dit
qu'effectivement la croissance
économique de certains pays en
développement
tu es la protection de l'environnement
ne sont pas compatibles si moi je dis
que ça tout à fait convenable a
effectivement à doit garder le droit
d'utiliser des énergies fossiles court
terme on va pas dire à l'inde
vous fermez toutes vos centrales outre
on dit on se met d'accord c'est ça la
négociation qui a lieu à ce moment à
paris et c'est un motif de fierté
d'ailleurs quel élu à parier je salue
aussi l'engagement du président de la
pub que les propos qu'il a tenus que
vous avez repasser à l'instant il ne les
aurais pas tenus il ya trois ans quand
il a été élu président rapport
c'est évident qu'il a changé sur ce
sujet quelle influence feu dans vos
rôles je pense que d'abord il a pris
conscience notamment par les échanges
internationaux des documents
vous n'êtes plus représenté au
gouvernement voilà hulot a fait un gros
travail auprès - il avait pris nicolas
hulot auprès de lui et ça n'a pas été
pour rien on le voit aujourd'hui
mais pour revenir au sujet il y donc en
parlera de françois hollande mais je
note qu'à ce stade de l'émission c'est
un premier satisfecit que vous lui
adressez
il faut saluer l'engagement du président
d'avic d'autant plus encore une fois que
ce n'est pas un écologiste à la base
françois hollande c'est un socialiste
qui ne se préoccupait pas beaucoup
d'écologie disons le il a dit cette
formule il ne faut pas considérer la
planète comme un vulgaire réservoir de
ressources naturelles je crois que lui
même avait peut-être cette conception il
ya encore cinq ou dix ans est ce que la
conférence risque de capoter sur le
clivage entre les pays du nord et pays
du sud est ce que c'est cela le
principal risque aujourd'hui pour moi on
ne crois pas parce que vous savez
l'afrique par exemple c'est je crois de
nous 3 % des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre dans le monde on pourra pas faire
porter l'effort sur l'afrique ça
n'aurait aucun sens le vrai enjeu il est
que les très gros émetteurs les états
unis d'amérique
l'europe le japon la chine le canada
l'australie
ces pays là se mettent d'accord entre
elles d'autres pays comme l'inde la
russie en disant voilà à partir du
moment où on fait tous des efforts
eh bien on y arrivera et les pays en
voie de développement c'est plutôt eux
qui vont en bénéficier c'est pas heureux
qu'on va évidemment faire porter
l'effort
est-ce qu'il faut une taxe tobin une
taxe sur les transactions financières
pour financer la transition énergétique
c'est un des moyens en tout cas pour
financer de la solidarité internationale
pour que les pays du sud savait que les
pays en voie de développement notamment
en afrique
leur enjeu ça va être plus de comment
ils s'adaptent qui au changement
climatique qui est déjà à l'oeuvre
puisqu'on parle de limiter la hausse des
températures à + 2 degrés on ne parle
pas de zéro et on dit que
aujourd'hui les propositions des états
tourne autour de +3 degrés et que si on
ne fait rien qu'on continue comme
aujourd'hui on sera plus 4 degrés et
donc il y à + 2 degrés il y aura quand
même une adaptation et la solidarité
internationale elle doit fonctionner
pour cela entre allan la fiscalité
écologique elle est au programme du
budget rectificatif
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'écologie
punitive
je ne sais pas qui l'appelle ainsi harry
est une formule qui revient beaucoup il
ya dans la bande de ségolène royal oui
mais ce coup-ci réaction oui mais sur ce
point c'est un point de divergence parce
que je crois que la fiscalité est un
outil pourra récompenser les
comportements vertueux est en effet
dissuader ceux qui ne veulent pas passer
avec un seul bâton baba me dire comme ça
après ça a toujours c'est toujours comme
ça que les sociétés ont progressé et par
tous et par ailleurs ces vertueux la
contribution climat énergie qui en
france commence modestement parce que là
aussi si on avait voulu d'un seul coup
mettre un coup de bambou a évidemment si
vous aviez dit le prix du carbone c'est
100 euros la tonne comme en suède
on souhaite aujourd'hui 100 euros la
tonne la suède n'est pas un pays qui
s'effondre n'est pas un pays en retard
au contraire c'est plutôt un pays en
avance et parce qu'ils ont commencé il
ya longtemps
donc nous on commence plus tôt au tir de
10 12 15 euros la tonne qui on va
continuer à augmenter et c'est ça qui va
nous permettre d'accompagner d'accélérer
le changement alors il ya les taxes et
il ya également les initiatives les
investissements privés on l'a vu à la
coop 21 vous avez été impressionné comme
nous tous par cet aréopage de
milliardaires derrière bill gates alors
le privé c'est aussi une manière
de trouver une solution c'est évident
qu'on ne fera pas la transition
énergétique cette lutte contre le
changement climatique sans les
entreprises les entreprises doivent être
des acteurs pas simplement quelques
milliardaires qui peut-être veulent se
donner un peu de confiance outre utile
veulent investir il veut leur retour sur
investissement etc ne tourne pas des
philanthropes
voilà un terrain et d'ailleurs il faut
pas se dire que ce sera que par la
philanthropie parce que sinon ça risque
d'avancer très lentement
non il faut que les grandes entreprises
qui sont des grosses émettrices parfois
les grandes entreprises de l'énergie
bien sûr mais aussi les entreprises de
l'automobile des transports beaucoup
d'industries en général les
investisseurs savaient qu'un mouvement
aujourd'hui qui a été lancé et qui
obtient des résultats on dit le
désinvestissement c'est à dire que ça
sera payant commencé à retirer leur
argent de des centrales à charbon de
tout ce qui est l'abrasion de lorient
d'orienter les investissements privés
vers ce qui va vers ce qui est utile
efficace
moi je suis convaincu d'ailleurs que ce
seront d'abord et avant tout des
investissements privés plutôt par
l'investissement public savait que
aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup
d'investissements privés dans le domaine
de l'énergie
ce qu'il faut c'est bien les orienter
vers les énergies renouvelables vers les
économies d'énergie plutôt que dans les
énergies fossiles écologie tout miser
sur l'innovation technologique
parce que ça cette innovation dans vos
rangs elle est combattue à temps réel
est une des raisons pour lesquelles on
parle des projets
autre ça n'est pas grave à voir avec le
règlement climatique
mais il est évident qu'aujourd'hui ce
qui nous permet de progresser dans les
transports par exemple ou dans la
production d'électricité
c'est l'innovation technologique c'est
un mélange de changement de comportement
avec l'innovation technologique
l'innovation technologique et dans
parfois au changement de comportement et
même des innovations technologiques qui
n'ont pas un rapport à première vue
directe avec l'énergie par exemple tout
ce qui est touré au numérique
on voit bien que ça accélère qui aurait
imaginé il ya dix ou quinze ans que le
covoiturage combattu rage ça ne coûte
rien à la collectivité aux particuliers
non seulement ça ne leur coûte rien et
ça leur fait faire des économies bien le
covoiturage a été développé grâce au
numérique alors vous êtes très optimiste
qu'on l'entend françois de rugy mais
quand même aujourd'hui j'ai vu il ya
défend une écologie pouzy voilà positive
si j'ai bien compris il ya une
statistique qui a dû vous peinez
aujourd'hui les ventes de voitures sont
repartis à la hausse le mois dernier en
france
oui mais compris les volkswagen est ce
que vous avez regardé la répartition à
l'intérieur de ses ventes de voitures et
je suis convaincu car c'est la tendance
depuis maintenant trois ans en france
les ventes de véhicules diesel baisse on
était quand on est arrivé aux
responsabilités en 2012 à plus de 75
pour cent soixante dix huit pour cent je
crois on est à moins de 58 % moins 20
points en 3 d la france besoin que la
moyenne de ses voisins européens
notamment un barack obama aujourd'hui à
évoquer multiples impératifs liés au
réchauffement
la croissance bien sûr mais il a
également évoqué la sécurité est ce
qu'il climat est véritablement un danger
de déstabilisation d'essayer c'est
évident - et veut pas alors il faut pas
tomber dans le panneau de vouloir tout
expliquer par le climat c'était la
question que j'avais la tension quand
j'entends certains ils disent le
terrorisme
islamistes djihadistes c'est lié à des
règlements climatique attention tout
n'est pas dans tout et ne mélangeons pas
tout quand j'entends certains qui dit si
on consomme moins de pétrole ça fera
moins de ressources financières pour
l'état islamique donc il aura moins de
mourir c'est vrai mais ça n'est pas la
principale le principal moyen de lutter
contre le terrorisme en france par
exemple aujourd'hui par la grêle j'ai
pas de raison et passion d'aider leurs
délires ory certain pays du monde sont
déstabilisés par les effets du
dérèglement climatique
la bande sahélienne en afrique et vous
avez remarqué que la bande sahélienne
c'est là où nous intervenons au mali par
exemple et bien et déstabilisé par la
progression du désert qui est lui même
dû au réchauffement climatique c'est
évident très bien donc pas de lien
abusif entre le terrorisme évidemment et
puis les difficultés climatiques qui
pèsent sur certaines régions on va
parler de la lutte contre le terrorisme
tout de suite quand même avec perrine
tarneaud qui arrive
craignez-vous pour les libertés
publiques françois de rugy avec
l'application de l'état d'urgence et
couteaux et or ce que disait à ce sujet
manuel valls ce matin l'état d'urgence
et c'est forcément une période
exceptionnelle et qui est lié parce que
ça c'est la constitution qui est très
précise à une menace immédiate or qui
lie à la menace il ya où l'état
d'urgence ou de nouveaux dispositifs qui
pourraient être intégrées dans la
constitution
alors l'état d'urgence et les craintes
qu'elle fait m l'état d'urgence si on va
bien suivi ce matin il faudra peut-être
prolonger cet état d'urgence au-delà du
26 février ce que vous y êtes favorable
vous êtes très pragmatique nous nous
avons voté moi j'ai voté la loi sur
l'état d'urgence qui était déjà une
prolongation puisque normalement c'est
une période de douze jours et en plus en
même temps nous avons voulu réformer à
l'initiative du gouvernement la loi de
1955 à 60 ans d'âge quand même normal
qu'on la réforme sur l'état d'urgence et
on l'a fait dans un sens des plus clairs
plus transparent d'abord on a supprimé
la censure de la presse qui était
possible dans la loi de 1955
nous avons on vous dit merci alors oui
parce que voyez qu'en plus certains
collègues vous l'aï revenus
ces listes voulait inclure et ferme du
monde a coupé le robinet à images
tout à fait j'ai été un de ceux qui me
suit un sergé le plus fortement en
commission et ensuite
heureusement en séance plénière à
l'assemblée cet amendement n'a pas été
redéposé mais pourquoi qu'elle tendre le
bras des chaînes d'info manifestement
mais je crois que c'était une confusion
totale entre des problèmes qui peuvent
exister mais qui sont de
l'autorégulation des chaînes notamment
les policiers avait fait état du fait
que si on mentionnait à l'écran est à
l'antenne un certain nombre de positions
précises de la police si vous avez à
l'ère numérique ce contrôle devient
quand même un tout petit peu plus
complicité ça n'avait aucun sens
et justement donc c'est un progrès par
ailleurs nous avons également renforcé
le contrôle judiciaire et nous avons
également renforcé le contrôle
parlementaire
évidemment l'état d'urgence ce sont des
mesures exceptionnelles qui font partie
de l'état de droit moi je veux le dire
très clairement celles et ceux qui
disent et qui entrerait en effet ce
n'est une ce n'est plus l'état de droit
si justement c'est une procédure qui est
dans notre droit mais l'état d'urgence
pourrait devenir un peu permanent alors
s'il est prolongé au-delà du 26 février
on a parlé de trois mois peut-être le
gouvernement envisage un mois
supplémentaire c'est parce que j'appelle
l'état permanent
comment savoir si notre sécurité le
nécessitait ce que vous en tant que
parlementaire vous allez exercer un
droit de contrôle sur cet état d'urgence
nous avons
interrogé le gouvernement cet après midi
même à l'assemblée nationale sur ce
sujet et le ministre de l'intérieur a
dit qu'il était tout à fait disponible
pour qu'il y ait tout à la fois au
niveau national nous proposons qu'il ya
une espèce de commissions de l'assemblée
pluraliste et du sénat avec tous les
groupes parlementaires majorité
opposition qui puisse auditionner à tout
moment non seulement le miz un terrain
mais les responsables mais c'est insensé
commission denquête 1 le temps jointe à
uniquement l'instar de l'état d'urgence
la commission spéciale à qui on veut
mais avec des gens qui connaissent bien
le sujet et puis que au niveau
départemental dans tous les départements
de france puisque les préfets ont été
invités à informer les élus et bien que
là aussi il ya des réunions régulières
et qu' on puisse interpeller sur tel ou
tel cas si la paresse litigieux et avec
les associations de défense des droits
de l'homme c'est déjà un petit peu ce
qui se fait puisque manuel valls
recevait cet après midi les présidents
des groupes politiques de l'assemblée et
du sénat ainsi que les présidents des
commissions des lois donc vous souhaitez
une première étape et nous oppresse on
préfère que ce soit un petit peu plus
précis à l'assemblée et au sénat avec
les responsables des services
alors il y à la polémique notamment sur
les assignations à résidence un 5e rang
et il ya eu une escarmouche aujourd'hui
à l'assemblée nationale entre bernard
cazeneuve qui répondait et qui a mis en
cause un de vos anciens amis en
l'écoutent
il répondait en fait aux castings et je
ne peux pas accepter que les forces de
sécurité aujourd'hui puis se prendre en
charge dans l'espace public
des casseurs parce qu'ils ont décidé
dans l'irrespect complet y compris
l'irrespect de la mémoire de ceux qui
sont tombés de jeter des projectiles sur
des forces de l'ordre en s'en prenant à
l'état et à ceux qui l'incarnent par
l'uniforme qui porte je ne l'accepterai
jamais et tous ceux qui l'acceptent sur
ses bancs dont monsieur mamère qui
s'agitent sont dans l'irresponsabilité
totale et je tiens à le dire très
clairement ici donc noël mamère et
irresponsable si l'on suit bien le
ministre de l'intérieur cet après midi à
l'assemblée nationale ont rejoint todo
critique en revanche il faut reconnaître
noël mamère au moins une cohérence et
que l'ue n'a pas voté l'état d'urgence
donc ça moi je lui reconnais au moins
cela d'autres ont voté mais sans cesse
qu'il était responsable à moi je pense
que dans la période actuelle oui c'est
irresponsable de dire qu'il ya besoin de
prendre aucune mesure particulière
ça c'est le refus de vote à d'urgence et
puis dès qu'il est appliqué et c'est là
que je dis qu'il ya des personnes qui
l'ont votée mais qui
en presse de dire que l'application ne
leur convient pas mais à ce moment-là
fallait pas le voter parce que c'est
normal qu'il y ait des assignations à
résidence où des perquisitions c'est le
but
mais comme une chance énorme incidence à
qui on parle de qui on parle
les militants écologistes des adhérents
d'europe écologie les verts par exemple
qui serait assigné à résidence parce
qu'ils sont adhérents d'europe écologie
les verts mais ça faut arrêter ça c'est
un gros mensonge c'est un énorme
mensonge c'est pas des militants
écologistes
moi je peux vous le dire parce que je
sais de quoi je parle à nantes avec
l'histoire de notre dame des landes les
a violées violent s'infiltre
systématiquement dans le mouvement
d'opposition pour le saboter d'ailleurs
et bien et c'est la même chose qui s'est
passé place de la république et c'est
non seulement abjecte d'avoir utilisé
les objets qui avaient été mis là à la
mémoire des victimes mais en plus avoir
dit on maintient cette manifestation il
faut y aller et encore après certains
responsables politiques notamment écolo
qui disent si cette manifestation
n'avait pas été interdite qui aurait pas
eu de débordements avant maintenant
c'est l'état qui va être responsable des
débordements qui ont été commis par ces
gens violents non les gens qui ont été
assignés à résidence
ils l'ont été parce que il y avait des
motifs qui montrait des maristes
par exemple il refusait à l'arial motif
oui à limerick dit fléau terroriste et
que l'objet principal mais aussi les
motifs et moins jeunes l'assument des
gens qui ne veulent pas respecter les
interdictions de manifestations qui
veulent organiser des manifestations
dont on sait qu'elles vont avoir ses
conséquences violent parce que ça et sur
la coque 21 on le savait bien avant les
attentats y avait des gens qui
préparaient des opérations de sabotage
dans des manifestations et d'ailleurs
qui manifestaient en disant on est anti
coptes 21 c'est grave pour la coop 21
nous on manifeste donc formellement en
étant l'état d'urgence au delà du
terrorisme mais au-delà de ce qui s'est
passé le 13 novembre
c'est emmanuelle cosse emmanuel pourquoi
elle s'est insurgée contre la mise en
cause elle bien là eu bien durant l
année
qu'est ce qu'elle a dit précise
emmanuelle cosse s'est insurgé contre la
mise en cause de militants écologistes
assigné à résidence et elle souhaite que
soit examiné l'ensemble des raisons qui
ont conduit à faire signe à sion elle
parle donc elle devient de militants
écologistes pas comme vous qu'est ce que
vous lui répondez
elle a raison sur le fait de dire
regardant les raisons qui ont conduit à
ces assignations à résidence mais moi je
ne les conteste pas a priori comme
certains le font pas ce que je vais vous
dire certains même ceux de mes collègues
par exemple qui ont voté l'état
d'urgence dès que j'ai mis en
application
ils ne l'acceptent pas bassement la
fallait pas le voter parce qu'on savait
que dans les applications il y aurait
assignation à résidence perquisitions et
moi je vais vous répondre sur la
question on dit ah mais ce ne sont pas
des jihadistes évidemment ce ne sont pas
des djihadistes que certains ont été mis
en assignation à résidence
il se trouve que nous sommes dans un
pays qui non seulement la menace
terroriste mais doit organiser cette
coop 21 et moi je voulais qu'on
maintienne l'organisation de la coop 20h
et donc ça nécessite de très gros moyens
la police de sécurité et vous croyez que
les gendarmes
les crs les policiers n'ont pas autre
chose à faire que d'aller essayer
d'aller sécuriser ces manifestations
dans cette période de cap 21
c'est pour ça et alors quand il ya des
gens gentils encore entendu ça à
l'assemblée nationale qui compare avec
les marchés de noël et les marathons
mais de qui se fout-on pour dire une
énormité pareille vous croyez que dans
les marathons
il ya des gens cagoulés casqués qui
veulent attaquer des policiers enfin on
sait très bien que ça m'est avis qu'on
interdit les rassemblements d'idées mais
qu'on autorise en revanche les
rassemblements de sportifs ou
effectivement les marchés de noël à vous
donner un exemple précis car j'ai eu à
travailler ça peut pas le passé là
dessus les matchs de foot on sait qu'il
peut y avoir des débordements par
exemple et marjorie est bien
actuellement et les supporters
actuellement l'acceptent tous les
déplacements à l'extérieur sont
interdits faire que vous êtes supporter
un nantais ça c'est le foot mais dans
une autre ville et bien c'est interdit
pourquoi parce que vous savez très bien
que ça nécessite un déploiement de
policiers et de crs supplémentaire quand
il y à ses déplacements alors j'avais
dans la période actuelle
encore une fois on a autre chose à faire
et jean luc mélenchon lui pour lui cet
état d'urgence est un instrument pour
criminaliser les mouvements
ils dénoncent le recours à des lettres
de cachet vous lui répondez quoi
mais de toute façon il le disait déjà
avant c'est toute cette thématique que
moi je conteste depuis toujours de la
criminalisation du mouvement social
c'est quelque chose qui faisait déjà
avant ils le disaient sur air france 1
ça mais rien à voir avec l'état
d'urgence non la procédure judiciaire
un judiciaire procédure judiciaire les
allées les personnes qui ont été
interpellées le matin pas la nuit le
matin sur mandat judiciaire il le
contestait aussi
donc si vous voulez ça c'est les gens
qui contestent systématiquement l'état
de droit et qui conseille
systématiquement l'autorité de l'état
quand ça va pas dans leur sens
ils voudraient ils sont pour l'autorité
de l'état quand ça va dans leur sens ils
sont pour l'autorité judiciaire quand ça
va dans leur sens mais pas quand ça va
dans l'absence est par ailleurs excusé
moi les violences est en train n'est pas
très démocrate alors je pense qu'il
n'est pas dans l'idée de respecter la
justice indépendante
ça je l' ai déjà dit au moment de
l'affairé air france vous êtes un
opposant à l'aéroport notre dame des
landes à mais est ce que vous espérez
quand même là vous avez peut-être
pouvoir me le dire que certains à dist
qui occupent les lieux tombe dans les
filets de l'état d'urgence n'est pas du
tout départ a d'ailleurs parce que la
police tout simplement là pour la même
raison que celle que j'ai dit que je ne
respecte pas les de la drogue c'est
l'effort grève oui mais la police et la
gendarmerie a autre chose à faire
actuellement
et le préfet de loire-atlantique l'a dit
officiellement et moi je le remercie de
cette franchise et cette honnêteté et de
ce bon sens qu' il n'y aurait pas
d'opérations particulières sur le front
si on peut dire de la zad de notre dame
des landes
parce que justement il y avait d'autres
choses à faire actuellement et d'autres
priorités pour l'état de droit pour
l'autorité de l'état et la sécurité des
français parce que moi je revendique je
les dis à l'assemblée nationale quand il
ya eu la loi sur l'état d'urgence
il ya une demande de sécurité des
français et il c'est normal c'est
légitime que l'état donc le gouvernement
donc le parlement répondre à cette
demande de sécurité je sais qu'un
certain nombre de gens à gauche chez les
écolos qui dès qu'on prononce le mot
sécurité c'est déjà une atteinte aux
libertés et bien non il ya cette demande
de sécurité c'est normal d'y répondre
car si on ne le fait pas moi je sais
comment ça se finira à ce moment là les
français ils se tourneront vers ceux qui
tiennent un discours extrémistes sur le
sujet et cela il existe
ils sont en fait vous adhérer pleinement
à la formule
manuel valls qui dit que cette
restriction des libertés elle a pour
objectif de protéger nos libertés
c'est ce qui n'arrête pas de répéter moi
je les dis à la tribune de l'assemblée
c'est protéger notre mode de vie libre
et notre société ouverte et tolérante
car nous sommes attachés à notre mode de
vie libre à notre société ouverte et
tolérante et pour cela on prend des
mesures de sécurité moi je refuse
d'opposer sécurité et liberté
encore une fois je vous dit dès qu'on
prononce le mot sécurité chez certains
c'est déjà une atteinte à la bien encore
viendront une petite question quand même
sur ce point parce que la france a quand
même prévenu le conseil de l'europe
c'était ce week-end on l'a appris
qu'elle allait enfreindre les droits de
l'homme
et vous savez pourquoi alors expliquez
nous mars que la convention européenne
des droits de l'homme prévoit qu'il y
ait des procédures de dérogation serre
que la france applique les procédures
c'est comme l'état de droit c'est que
l'état d'urgence c'est quelque chose qui
est prévu dans notre état de droit on le
on le dit on le fait en toute
transparence
et pourquoi moi j'étais si attachés
justement la liberté de la presse dans
ces circonstances là c'est parce que la
presse est totalement libre à ce moment
là de dire mais attendez comment ça se
fait monsieur untel a été assigné à
résidence est bien justifiée et vous
pouvez faire confiance à tout un tas
d'organes de presse bon évidemment
raconter la moindre le moindre excès de
zèle et il peut y en avoir et idées à ce
moment-là tout à fait normal de le
condamner d'interpeller gouvernement ou
les autorités préfectorales pour qu'il
fasse qu'il revienne vous regrettez que
ces mesures n'ont pas été prises
finalement après le mois de janvier
après le premier attentat
ses traits à paris mais pas non plus
défendu avec fougue d'état d'urgence pas
le même
à ce moment là mais on refera pas
l'histoire ce qui compte c'est d'agir
ici et maintenant c'est le reproche en
tout cas de la droite et et de nicolas
sarkozy de nicolas sarkozy qui a déclaré
que la bienséance nous en empêcher
d'aborder les vrais sujets comme par
exemple le sujet de l'identité nationale
est ce qu il a raison
on va écouter il a été président de la
république pendant cinq ans je crois que
personne ne l'a empêché de il est abordé
il avait mis le moindre sujet il est mis
sur la table ce sujet de l'identité
nationale où il avait été extrêmement
critique n est pas vrai il avait
commandé ou préfets d'organiser des
débats dans tous les départements de
france sur ce sujet la vérité c'est que
ça avait tourné au fiasco parce que lui
il voulait instrumentaliser cette
question moi je vais vous dire je n'ai
pas de problème avec le mot identité en
ce qui me concerne je pense qu'il fera
par les entités nationales non plus je
pense qu'il faut en parler de l'identité
nationale d identité régionale
moi je défends les identités
régional et j'entends des gens à droite
qui ne veulent pas en entendre parler
par exemple les identités d'origine il
ya des français qui ont une double
culture peut-être même certains une
triple culture c'est une richesse en
tout cas cela fait partie de l'identité
nationale française à l'époque avait été
rejetée mais quand manuel valls c'est
aujourd'hui qu'il faut reconstruire à la
république qu'il faut retrouver
finalement des bases des fondements à
cette république
il pense à quoi à votre avis ben et la
république d'abord c'est quelque chose
qui sera toujours en construction
jamais je n'y ai mobinil vallée
détruites là c'est vrai que à la fois
les attentes à certaines situations
moi je voudrais pas me fais pas les
attentats il parle effectivement que la
bien pensante qui a pu empêcher de
regarder en face certains problèmes de
la société
c'est histoire de bien pensants faisons
attention ce nom mais justement la junte
et non dit ce qu'il veut est-ce qu'on
n'a pas toléré trop de choses qui
finalement va favoriser un autre la
montée du communautarisme boyer du
communautarisme en tout cas de
l'islamisme radical
un certain nombre d'endroits il faut
bien sérier les problèmes et en effet la
radicalisation allant jusqu'à
l'engagement dans le djihadisme et dans
le thé rose aimée à sa planète la salle
horizon là sinon sous-estimé en tout cas
on n'a pas voulu prendre des mesures
concrètes vous dire on a fait un rapport
parlementaire en 2013 c'est christophe
cavard député écologiste voyez ça
pourrait surprendre et c'est un
écologiste qui avait fait un rapport sur
les dysfonctionnements de la ferme ra et
il avait préconisé un certain nombre de
choses en matière de police de sécurité
notamment aussi le fichier européen pnr
sur les voyages en avion mais là elle
aussi préconisé et des brigades
d'éducateur spécialisé dans la détection
justement des dérives le djihadiste
parce que les éducateurs actuelle ils ne
sont pas ils n'ont pas la culture la
formation pour le faire et donc ça ce
sont des mesures concrètes qu'il faudra
aussi prends moi même et françois de
rugy
ce genre de rapport on l'avait eu ci
oscille au sénat avec la commission
denquête liés au réseau djihadiste et
pourtant rien n'a été fait depuis ce
rapport de l'assemblée nationale en 2013
depuis ce rapport la commission denquête
ici l'année dernière au sénat
on a quand même laissé les filets les
choses donc à une part de responsabilité
importante de ce gouvernement est sans
doute aussi du précédent attendez il
faut pas non plus expliquer ça moi je
suis d'accord avec manuel ben ali a pas
d' excuses sociologie
seulement les a pas d'excusé naturel jeu
international sur le terrorisme
il ya des personnes qui prennent la
responsabilité de s'engager dans le
terrorisme de se faire sauter ce sont
les résolutions ont été proposés il faut
pas il faut faire attention parce que je
vois dans certains milieux de gauche
qu'on est en train de transformer les
victimes en coupables et les coupables
en victime la proche des manuels macron
qui a dit que la france avait un terreau
favorable
il m'arrive d'être d'accord avec la
ruelle mâcon y compris quand il secoue
le cocotier là j'ai trouvé qu'il allait
sur une mauvaise piste en effet et
qu'ils disent est sur une mauvaise pente
militaire en revanche je pense que il y
a dans notre pays trop d'inertie trop de
conservatisme sur plein de sujets y
compris ces sujets là et donc en effet
on fait des rapports nous au parlement
il y à des sociologues qui tire la
sonnette d'alarmé il ya des enseignants
et autres et on se dit oh bah tant qu'on
peut continuer comme aujourd'hui sans
retouche et nos structures on le fait ça
c'est une erreur
d'une manière générale mais ces paliers
spécialement aux attentats quand même
la réponse très sécuritaire de françois
hollande il a repris une partie des
quand même des arguments de la droite
elle est liée directement aux événements
du 13 novembre à ce qu' il ya encore une
fois je vous le disais
besoin une demande légitime de sécurité
d'une part par ailleurs moi je veux le
dire le terrorisme c'est d'abord un
problème de sécurité intérieure y
compris par rapport à l'international
certains qui disent on va aller faire la
guerre en syrie on réglera le problème
du terrorisme il faut créer alors
descendre de déradicalisation c'est la
prof au regard d'un phare de nicolas
sarkozy mais manuel valls a dit que le
gouvernement allait l'étudier vous savez
qui est des expériences en prison qui
sont menées d'ores et déjà et c'est une
des conséquences pour le coup des
événements de janvier savait déjà qu'on
sait nous on propose cette brigade
d'éducateurs spécialisés sur ces
questions là pour aller à l'art à la
rencontre des jeunes et détecter les
problèmes
donc oui il faut pas avoir là-dessus
faut pas écarter par avance un certain
nombre d'idées ou de solutions mais il
faut pas non plus dire faire croire aux
français qu'il ya des recettes miracles
et que à si on avait écouté intel ou si
on avait écouté une telle on n'en serait
pas là
c'est trop facile de dire ça c'est un
problème interne on trouve dans plein de
pays les attentats s'est il n'y a pas
que la france qui est si vrai et
dernière question est ce qu'on pourrait
instaurer un délit de consultation des
sites jihadistes sans porter atteinte à
un droit d'information droit de
s'informer
on a fait des choses dans la une loi
anti terroriste qu'on avait fait il ya
déjà plus d'un an et demi on a fait la
loi renseignement il ya des mesures de
détection
il faut pas tomber dans l'excès de dire
que monsieur sarkozy d'y consulter
simplement un site savait déjà
on est un apprenti que j'ai à 10 là
c'est excessif merci beaucoup perrine
troisième partie de preuves par 3
maintenant françois de rugy avec
stéphanie le rouge de la fp qui va nous
rejoindre et cette question un parti
écolo certes il encore à quelque chose
on en parlera également dans le cadre
des régionales bien sûr et on vous pose
cette question alors que vous avez vous
même créer votre parti je le disais tout
à l'heure et que les listes europe
écologie les verts semblent plutôt dans
l'impasse lors de ces élections dont le
premier tour aura lieu dimanche
écoutons jean daniel lévy de harris
interactive on est face à des français
qu'ils sont aujourd'hui
attentif au réchauffement climatique au
dérèglement climatique le face à des
français qui sont interrogatif sur le
lien entre
dérèglement climatique problèmes en
matière ample manteau et les
conséquences en matière de santé mais en
même temps il ne voit pas aujourd'hui
des solutions qui sont exprimés hier de
la part des écologistes et que ce camp
là aujourd'hui et va voter de manière
assez nette en faveur des socialistes
voilà stéphanie le rouge comme nous
accueillant pour la première fois sur le
plateau de faire trois mètres sans faire
de la techno bonsoir stéphanie vos
questions à françois de rugy
alors vous le disais tout à l'heure
michel le monde entier semble s'être
emparée de la question écologique et du
coup se pose cette question est-ce qu'il
ya encore une utilité à un ou des partis
écologistes puisqu'ils semblent se
multiplier assez naturellement il y a
une utilité c'est évident pour la prise
de conscience car à une époque nous
n'avions pas ce niveau de prise de
conscience dans les discours je crois
qu'il y a une utilité aujourd'hui dans
le passage des discours aux actes des
discours aux décisions et à la mise en
oeuvre de ses décisions dans la durée
car on le voit au niveau international
au niveau européen malheureusement au
niveau européen l'europe a parfois été à
la pointe en matière écologique par
exemple sur les normes anti pollution
des voitures ou sur les normes
d'émissions de co2 l'europe est à la
pointe il faut le dire mais dans
d'autres domaines malheureusement
l'europe aujourd'hui un peu tendance à
régresser par exemple la politique
énergétique
donc là l'utilité d'avoir des élus
écologistes et responsables économiques
des ministres écologistes dans ces
négociations internationales comme dans
la politique à mener dans notre pays
dans nos régions demain est bien là je
crois que oui il y a encore un grand
besoin d'élus écologique vous même vous
avez créé
votre parti écologiste en quittant élevé
avec straka à la fin de l'été et vous
avez affirmé d'emblée votre soutien à la
politique du gouvernement
est ce que vous êtes satisfait de ce que
fait le gouvernement français en matière
d'écologie on pense notamment au dossier
très controversé de notre dame des
landes dont vous parliez tout à l'heure
mais nous nous avons dit que nous étions
dans la majorité
ce que nous avons été élus en 2012 dans
la majorité il ya des gens comme cécile
duflot qui ont décidé de sortir de la
majorité je sais pas comment ils l'ont
expliqué à celles et ceux qu'ils avaient
élu dans la majorité en 2012 honda ont
toutes et tous et est élu député ou
sénateur dans la majorité ils ont
expliqué que le programme a lancé
n'était pas suivie et que ce n'était pas
la politique pour laquelle il expliqué
au bout de 22 mois en avril 2014 quand
manuel valls a été nommé un premier
ministre mais tout le monde a compris
que c'est surtout parce que ça leur
plaisait pas de manuel valls au premier
ministre et en 22 mois c'était normal
qu'on n'ait pas fait tout le programme
par ailleurs et c'est évident que depuis
trois ans et demi la politique
écologique de cette majorité de ce
gouvernement pourrait être beaucoup plus
ambitieuse et c'est là que nous pensons
nous cherchons tout le temps à pousser
plus fort et c'était entre dans le
gouvernement voulait d'ailleurs en tout
cas si nous étions ça oui nous avons la
faiblesse de penser que des écologistes
au gouvernement ferait plus d'écologie
que des socialistes
voilà et donc ça ce sont des réalités
simple que les français comprennent très
bien et je crois d'ailleurs c'est la
mission qu'ils assigne aux écologistes
par ce vote les écologistes pour les
élections régionales vous être pas
forcément en accord avec vos partenaires
sur le sujet de notre dame des landes
est ce que ça c'est pas un problème sur
le coran et supprimer nos désaccords il
en a évidemment ça fait longtemps que ça
dure pour ce qui est de notre à la
maison ça ne nous a pas empêchés de
travailler ensemble sur d'autres sujets
et heureusement vous imaginez le client
en france on devait gouverner qu'avec
les gens avec qui on est 100 % d'accord
mais on gouverne aurait jamais met en
ménage important parce qu'un parti
socialiste il n'a pas la majorité à lui
tout seul à l'assemblée nationale là
encore vaguement l'illusion d'avoir la
majorité à lui tout seul mais en france
les français n'ont jamais voté à plus de
50 % pour la seule partie les français
et ils sont
verts et donc les courants politiques
qui les représente le sont également
mais ce que les français nous demandent
en revanche c'est d'arriver à nous
mettre d'accord à passer des compromis
et c'est ce que nous revendiquons les
écologistes l'ensemble des recours
devait être examinée le président de la
république s'y était engagé et
finalement de manière assez récente
manuel valls a dit que les travaux enfin
la préfecture a annoncé le lancement des
travaux et manuel valls a approuvé donc
voilà est ce que le gouvernement là
après avoir pris un engagement
finalement n'est pas revenu dessus ce
qui pourrait être gênant pour vous
surtout pour les lieux que vous êtes de
cette région est depuis ce que je disais
tout à l'heure le préfet de loire
atlantique s'est exprimée compte tenu du
contexte sécuritaire extrêmement lourd
dans lequel nous vivons
mais par ailleurs je souhaite est fait
c'est très clair et mon mouvement
souhaite qu'on en revienne à 7
justement cette expression de compromis
sur le respect jusqu'au bout des
procédures juridiques encore usa et pas
par fétichisme du compromis ou des
procédures juridiques par bon sens
vous n'allez quand même pas lancer le
chantier d'un aéroport quelque chose
aussi lourd si à la fin ce projet alors
qu'il dont le chantier a déjà démarré
pour être déclarée illégale par un
tribunal français c'est l'état de droit
là aussi c'est l'état de droit alors on
peut dire la procédure française elle
est trop longue et trop complexe moi je
le pense mais il faut la réformer en
attendant il faut l'appliquer telle
qu'elle est parce que les recoins n'ont
pas pu avoir lieu avant la déclaration
d'utilité publique moi je pense qu'il
vaudrait mieux consignes allégations
duty public
bon les recours ont été tuées quand tous
les cas recours ont été épuisés si la
décision est favorable bien vous vous
rendrez la décision initiale de consoles
c'est aéroport vous ne cesserez de le
contester
allez moi j'avais même proposé comme
jean rased et là c'est un référendum si
le résultat
était pas dans notre sens on
respecterait le résultat ça c'est
d'accord démocratie un autre dossier
emblématique c'est fessenheim il y avait
une promesse du candidat françois
hollande qui semble pour le moins mettre
du temps à être
réalisée qu'est-ce que vous le président
le gouvernement même la ministre de
l'ecologie qu'à un moment donné avait
évoqué la possibilité de fermer une
autre sans talent tu fais un tout le
monde a redit il y a quelques semaines
que c'était la fermeture de fessenheim
qui était prévu et qui serait réalisé
qu'il y aurait en quelque sorte un
processus irréversible pour que cette
centrale soit fermée qu'elle ne puisse
pas réouvrir tombe autant moi je
souhaite que dans ces domaines là comme
son hôte il y ait plus de clarté
oui le gouvernement gagnerait le
président et lui gagnerait à être plus
clair sur ses engagements écologiques
alors l'une des raisons est que votre
rupture avec europe ecologie c'est
l'absence d'union de la gauche
la part de vos amis avec la perspective
d'une montée en puissance du front
national qui se confirme sondage après
sondage j'ai envie de dire presque 1
heure après heure
écoutez cet échange à distance entre
pierre gattaz le président du medef qui
a pris position aujourd'hui et marine le
pen
mon problème n'est pas le front national
mon problème c'est leur programme
économique du front national qui nous
rappelle étrangement le programme
l'extrême gauche et le programme de 1981
du programme commun de la gauche qui
nous a conduits en moins de deux ans
dans le mur assez bien ump/ps medef même
combat parfait vous voyez moi demain la
semaine dernière je suis allé rencontrer
le medef de la somme
demain je vais aller rencontrer le medef
six ont des choses à me dire ils me le
diront
mais moi les gens qui veulent pas
débattre je trouve toujours ça étrange
vous salue et françois de rugy la prise
de position de monsieur bazin je suis
pas sûr que ce soit très utile surtout
les arguments qu'il utilise dire c'est
le programme de 80 je sais pas si c'est
le souvenir de son père qui était déjà
le le chef du patronat à l'époque -
franchement je crois que ça sert pas à
grand chose
il ya un débat politique électorale qui
est en cours à lons qui va aller jusqu'à
son terme c'est dimanche 6 décembre
premier tour des élections régionales le
13 c'est le deuxième tour moi j'appelle
les français a voté largement ça aussi
c'est une réponse concrète à invoquer
les valeurs de la république de la
démocratie de l'état de droit si on ne
la fait pas vivre au moins concrètement
par son vote ça servira pas à grand
chose
ça c'est une réponse concrète aussi à ce
que nous avons vécu depuis le début de
l'année
des attentats mais au-delà de cela que
le débat politique ait lieu sur tous les
sujets y compris le programme économique
en effet du front national je le pense
est dangereux pour nos régions et pour
la france
mais je crois que les prises de position
comme ça un peu à l'emporte-pièce vont
plutôt brouiller les choses qu'elles ne
vont les clarifier face aux risques du
fn
emmanuelle cosse s'est prononcé très
clairement hier pour un retrait des
listes élevé si cela doit permettre de
faire battre le fn on sait est codée au
ps il ya un débat qui n'est pas
clarifiée sur la fusion le retrait le
maintien est ce que vous vous avez une
position claire à faire valoir lvg pas
très bien compris cette prise de
position si j'avais pas compris que les
listes ee lv avait vocation à se
maintenir au deuxième tour déjà ça veut
dire qu'elle ferait plus de 10%
bon pour la voir mais je crois que vaut
mieux être modeste et si c'était le cas
est ce que ça veut dire qu'elle aurait
vocation à se maintenir
c'est à dire qu'elle n'aurait pas
vocation à fusionner avec la gauche que
pour essayer de gagner
alors si c'est le cas ce serait encore
encore plus l'éloignement de ce qui a
toujours été
normalement la stratégie des écologistes
qui était le rassemblement de la gauche
et jean lacoste hergault verniolle qu
elle a très clairement dit qu'elle
agirait en fonction de ce que ferait le
ps mais ce qu'on comprend c'est que elle
invite le ps à se retirer en cas de
risque dans la salle quelques heures
faire la production qui englobait toute
la gauche moi ce que je veux dire très
clairement bien sûr il faut attendre le
premier tour mais enfin on ne va pas
croire que tout d'un coup le front
national va s'effondrer le 6 décembre
dans les urnes parce que c'est pas
simplement les sondages et c'est pour ça
que moi je le dis depuis de nombreux
mois pas simplement avait levé jeudi à
l'ensemble de la gauche et des
écologistes
regardons la réalité en face lucidement
le front national ne cesse d'augmenter
depuis des années là aussi c'est pas la
gauche la droite en 2012 après 5 ans de
sarkozy 18% pour marine le pen en 2014
aux européennes après deux ans de
françois hollande 25% pour marine le pen
ensuite aux cantonales les élections
départementales vraiment locales 25% de
nouveau pour le front national
donc le malheureusement la surprise aux
élections régionales ce serait que le
front national descendent en dessous de
ses niveaux je n'y crois pas donc donc
il faudra faire face à cette situation
et moi j'inviterai le soir je le dis dès
maintenant au dialogue entre les listes
on va dire de droite classique et de
gauche de gouvernement qui pourrait se
maintenir à dialoguer à se mettre autour
de la table cas échéant j'espère que
c'est quand même possible dans notre
pays de se mettre autour de la table
même si on a pu marquer plus tôt les
divergences de projets de bilan dans nos
régions et à ce moment là on verra
quelle est la meilleure solution région
par région pour empêcher haute le front
national entre les deux se gagner dans
les rues l'air dans les trios les et à
ce moment là oui tous les clés les
solutions doivent être envisagés oui
parfaitement
car si on veut sincèrement éviter que le
front national gagne une région
simplement par l'effet des triangulaires
s'ils gagnent région parce qu'il a la
majorité absolue c'est que les habitants
de cette région l'auront voulu
majoritairement mais s'il gagne avec 34
35 %
simplement parce qu'il ya eu une
triangulaire à ce moment là je pense que
ça n'aurait pas été responsable moi j'en
appelle à la responsabilité appelé
premier tour il faut se rassembler ça
c'est clair que pour le premier temps il
faut se rassembler parce que si la
gauche les écologistes ne se rassemblent
pas
c'est un processus d'auto élimination
d'acteur on ne compte plus pour le
deuxième position se dire que le choix
non mais les électeurs allemands sachent
près ce que vous dites qu'ils ont un
bulletin de vote europe écologie les
verts je leur dis pas ce que je lis pas
dans l opposition les rencontres tout le
temps et je les ai je l'ait encore fait
ce week-end dans ma circonscription à
nantes orvault
ils me disent que et ils sont inquiets
et je sens une inspiration qui sait ce
que vous leur dites quand ils ont le
choix effectué rassemblant un but un
bulletin un culte à europe écologie ne
leur soit douche je suis allé faire
campagne dans beaucoup de régions et
pour des listes de gauche et écologistes
de rats sont lents car il ya des
écologistes sur les délices de gauche
sortante
monsieur queyranne en auvergne
rhône-alpes et a beaucoup de courriers
haricots noirs sur sa liste monsieur
bartolone en ile de france monsieur
clergeau en pays de la loire je pourrais
multiplier les exemples monsieur
saintignon dans le nord-pas-de-calais
picardie bien j invite les électeurs à
se rassembler avec c'est surtout ne pas
s'emparer d'un bulletin de vote avec le
logo europe écologie n'a compris la
division je pense ne servira que la
droite et l'extrême ce que vous en
appelez on a parlé beaucoup de l'union
nationale parce que vous en appeler à
l'union nationale contre le front
national
je suis assez favorable pour ma part à
ce que l'on regarde quand on peut
travailler ensemble je veux dire je vais
même plus loin je pense qu'en 2017
l'élection présidentielle se jouera sur
la capacité de celui qui pourra face à
marine le pen incarné un large
rassemblement je pense que françois
hollande peut le faire d'ailleurs
mais qu'il doit s'en donner les moyens
que nous fatiguer de candidat écologiste
à la présidentielle
ça ne sert à rien qu'à d'abord affaibli
à l'écologie parce que faire un pour
cent 2 % mais même là peut-être 5 6%
c'est ce qu'on voit à quoi ça sert sinon
à mettre en scène l'impuissance de
l'écologie et ensuite il ya un esprit de
responsabilité
moi je me placerai toujours comme on le
disait tout à l'heure sur les attentats
avec l'état d'urgence les questions de
sécurité il faut faire preuve d'esprit
de responsabilité
ben oui on aimerait bien organiser des
manifestations mais on voit que dans la
période actuelle c'est pas une bonne
chose et mais on en tire les
conséquences concrètes les élections on
voit que le front national peut gagner
on en tire les conséquences concrètes
ont fait preuve d'esprit de
responsabilité vous êtes même si ça nous
oblige à réviser des réflexes qu'on
avait jusqu'à présent et puis moi je
vais vous dire je crois qu'on surjoue en
france et on crève de ça des divergences
gauche-droite sur jouer qui
du coup amène à des surenchères de
discours avant les élections monsieur
sarkozy est repartie totalement sur
cette voie là avec un certain nombre de
discours monsieur mélenchon dont parlait
tout à l'heure
aussi à gauche de la même façon et puis
à la fin qui est-ce qui profite de cela
c'est le front national parce que y
compris une partie des électeurs qui
votent pour le fondation j'en suis
convaincu le font parce qu'ils ont
l'impression que le reste de la classe
politique finalement est dans les
postures alors vous voulez une nouvelle
configuration politique c'est clair
autour de françois hollande avec wade
des éléments de centre-droit de centre
gauche ce qu'il fallait avoir une grande
coalition en france une grande coalition
pour faire un certain nombre de réformes
importantes
contrairement à ce que croit un certain
nombre de dirigeants politiques qu'ils
essayent de faire croire ce n'est pas
une majorité arraché aux forceps par le
scrutin majoritaire à l'assemblée
nationale qui permet de faire des
grandes réformes
l'expérience était à la montre j'ai que
vous aviez quand vous avez lancé donc
votre mouvement écologiste qui est sous
la bannière de l'ue des oeufs de jean
vincent placé c'est un petit peu
compliqué chez les écolos
et tout cela des vocations
éventuellement à fédérer encore plus
largement avec pourquoi pas génération
écologie cap 21 le mouvement de robert
hue et c'est finalement on a
l'impression que ça n'a pas vraiment
pris ce n'est pas les logiques de partie
justement chacun se dit même avec des
petits partis à je veux quand même
garder mon petit parti je ne sais pas
quel sera le résultat des élections
régionales
s'il se profile tels que on le voit dans
les études d'opinion et dans les
élections précédentes
et bien moi j'inviterai les uns et les
autres à ce qu'on révise justement nos
fonctionnements de partie c'est
justement ces fonctionnements où chacun
défend sa petite boutique où finalement
le parti devient une fin en soi alors
que c'est un moyen pour défendre des
idées présenter des candidats c'est rien
d'autre que ça un parti politique
sinon ça devient quelque chose de fermé
deux secteurs est ce que je le dis avec
quand même et à l'heure d'été est ce que
les électeurs vous ont suivi c'est à
dire que au départ vous aviez 300
adhérents peut-être en tout cas c'est ce
qu'on a vu à la naissance de l'idée e s
que il y en a davantage aujourd'hui est
ce qu'il ya un mouvement une dynamique
oui mais pour ce qui est des électeurs
là les élections régionales seront déjà
un premier test en effet les électeurs
sont les seuls juges ou en tout cas ce
n'est pas le jugement dernier
mais en dernier ressort c'est le
jugement auquel nous devons tous et
toutes nous souhaite c'est la différence
d'ailleurs avec monsieur gattaz ou
d'autres examens nous nous soumettons
jugement des électeurs n'avaient combien
d'adhérents aujourd'hui vous
personnellement écologie ça nous en
avons plusieurs centaines mais moi je ne
fais pas de gonflette sur les chiffres
d'adhérents et nous sommes un mouvement
en construction et nous verrons début de
l'année nous ferons un premier point
puis surtout au bout d'un an de
fonctionnement mais nous nous inscrivons
dans la durée
parce que les écologistes réaliste
pragmatique responsable l'écologie
positive que nous défendons et bien elle
a vocation à durer et je suis convaincu
qu'elle s'est les électeurs qui
s'intéresse à l'écologie c'est cette
écologie là qu'ils veulent
qui de vous deux jean vincent placé a le
plus envie d'être ministre alors ça je
n'avais jamais pensé à cette question
parce que là ça frise la psychanalyse et
moi je ne fais pas de la psychanalyse en
politique ce que nous partageons
ensemble nous sommes différents
algorithmes illustrent non ce que nous
partageons ensemble c'est d'inscrire
l'écologie et les écologistes dans les
institutions et en effet dans les
responsabilités il ya que aux
écologistes qu'on demande quand il se
présente aux élections s'ils se
présentent pour être élu
ou s'ils se présentent pour les
installations cnt c'est incroyable on se
présente pas aux élections moi je le dis
hein
s'il ya des gens qui se présentent aux
élections puis qu'ils nomment et façon
c'est pas d'être élu qui nous intéresse
ce qui se présente pas ça facilitera le
choix vous étirer que françois hollande
fasse entrer des ide au gouvernement
2012 16
je ne m rien je ne suis pas là dans
l'espoir ou dans la tente
vous avez fait passer votre message j'ai
déjà dit que c'était à françois hollande
de prendre l'initiative qu'ils
jugeraient bonne pour rassembler pour
l'élection de 2017 et pour défendre le
bilan des cinq ans et moi je souhaite
que jusqu'au bout en face des réformes
et des changements
merci stéphane et immersif en train de
rire si merci à tous bon soir a très
vite